-Oh, blast.
-[chuckles]
Another round of biscuit Jenga to you.
How come my tower always collapses
and yours just stays there?
Steady hand, even temperament.
I can't believe there's something
you're better at than me.
-It's never happened before.
-No...
I'll practise, you start the show.
Remember, steady hand,
even temperament.
You'll get there, kid.
Welcome to The Great British Baking Show.
Hang on a minute.
-Is yours glued together?
-Is that not in the rules?
Oh, I'd run now if I was you.
Paul, start the car!
Sandi's kicking off!
[theme music playing]
[Michael] Scared about this week.
Biscuit week is, like,
the nightmare for everyone.
[Alice] Had some really
strange dreams last night.
Biscuits that wouldn't work,
chocolate everywhere,
waking up in cold sweats
thinking about biscuits.
I don't make a lot of biscuits,
so I practised as much as I could.
My wife's the biscuit freak.
She's put me right.
"Bake this, bake that. Stop moaning."
[laughing]
[Noel] Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's biscuit week and time
for your Signature Challenge.
So the judges would like you to make
12 decorated chocolate biscuit bars.
They must contain at least
one baked biscuit element,
be coated in chocolate,
and beautifully decorated.
This is a chance
to show off your personalities.
In biscuit form.
Exactly. Not just in biscuit form,
biscuits with little chocolate coats on.
-Ah, what kind?
-Cagoules.
[all chuckle]
[Sandi] You've got 2.5 hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Biscuits. I love eating biscuits.
I'm not sure about making them.
I make dog biscuits,
and dog biscuits are fine
because your judges are really
complimentary whatever you make.
Are you boiling?
Do your thing. Right.
[Paul] It's biscuit week and we're
kicking off with chocolate bars.
The addition of the chocolate
makes it a bit harder.
I don't want a whole lump of chocolate
with a little bit of biscuit in it.
I want to taste the biscuit itself.
If they've said it'll snap, it must snap.
Crumbly, it must be crumbly.
If it's going to be shortbread,
we want it really short.
The biscuit has to be perfect.
This all boils down to timing.
Baking the biscuit, preparing the filling,
cooling that sufficiently
before the chocolate is put on,
because if they don't, it will collapse.
Good morning, Henry.
-Hello.
-Hello, Henry.
-Are you wearing a tie?
-I am.
You're the only person I've ever seen
in the tent wearing a tie.
I thought, "If I go out,
I wanna go out looking sharp."
[Noel] 'Cause you don't look young enough.
You need to look like
you're still at school.
Like a prepubescent American schoolboy.
[all laugh]
Tell us all about your chocolate biscuit.
-It's hazelnut shortbread...
-[Paul] Okay.
...with a coffee and cardamom mousse.
-A mousse?
-And then hazelnut caramel.
-Wow. Sounds incredible, and difficult.
-It tastes lovely.
[Noel] English student Henry
pays for university life
by playing the organ at his local church.
[playing "I Vow to Thee My Country"]
His ambitious six-layer biscuit bars
will also feature chocolate hazelnuts,
popping candy, and a dark chocolate shell.
The flavours sound absolutely wonderful.
-[Paul] I can't wait.
-Quite a sophisticated palette
-for such a young nipper. [laughs]
-Sophisticated toddler.
[all laugh]
-Thank you.
"Sophisticated toddler,"
that's beautiful. [laughs]
[Sandi] Sophistication
is also Steph's aim...
[Steph] Easy, tiger.
[Sandi] ...but her key flavour
is not for toddlers.
Coffee, lots of coffee.
Do I sound like I'm high on it as well?
That's really nice.
[Sandi] In her spare time, Steph enjoys
Chester's café culture with mum Jane.
No fingers, no fingers.
[Sandi] She'll sandwich caramel between
two layers of coffee-flavoured shortbread.
And to give her biscuit texture the edge,
she's got a secret weapon.
[Steph] I'm using semolina
in my biscuit dough.
It makes it nice and short,
bit of crunch to it. I like it.
Oh! [chuckles]
This is the recipe that my mum
and my granny use for shortbread.
It should be fail-safe.
I could be kicked out of Scotland
if I do bad shortbread.
It's got your great-granny's writing...
[Noel] When Michael
visits his parents in Perthshire,
consulting the family cookbook
isn't their only shared pastime.
[playing music]
His traditional Scottish shortbread
will be infused with flavours
from his adopted southern home.
[Michael] It's based
on Stratford Gin.
They infuse the gin
with lemon and rosemary.
I was using the gin in the bake,
but it's so strong,
it stops everything from setting.
It's now just in the icing,
and I'll have that for when
I feel a bit sad later on. [chuckles]
[Noel] Michael's not the only baker
turning to the bottle.
I love mojitos.
They're my favourite cocktail.
The really sharp acidity of the limes
and the coolness of the mint
is balanced out
by the sweet white chocolate.
That's it, good boy.
[Sandi] Vet Rosie takes
to the saddle to relax...
Come on.
[Sandi] ...even if it sometimes
becomes a busman's holiday.
[horse neighs]
Although she's leaving out the rum,
balancing the other strong mojito flavours
will be a delicate operation.
I did do eye surgery on a horse this week.
What was wrong with the horse's eye
'cause I've got a bad eye?
He had a worm in his tear duct.
-So gross.
-Oh, my goodness.
This is horrific. [laughs]
-This is my life.
-Mm, biscuit anyone?
I'm making millionaire shortbread,
but I wanted to make it a bit different
'cause it tends to be quite sickly.
So, I just got some sour cherries
just to, like, give it some sharpness.
There we go, buddy.
[Sandi] Barman Jamie relaxes between
shifts by jamming with his twin Alex...
-Ugh!
-[laughing]
[Sandi] ...who is backing
Jamie's combination of sour cherries,
caramel and butter-rich
crumbly shortbread.
They did break in practice.
'Cause they're going in the mould,
it'll be coated in chocolate
and held together.
It's not ideal but it's not the end
of the world if it does crumble.
[Noel] With texture
as important as taste...
[Amelia] Just adding ground pistachios.
It is a really nice crumbly biscuit.
...caution is needed
when adding flavours...
I tried it with fresh rosemary,
but it got wetter.
The orange zest
gives it a nice fruity kick.
[Noel] ...which could have
a dramatic effect...
[Henry] Why are you cracking?
[Noel] ...on the bite
of their baked biscuit.
Oh, God.
That's matcha powder.
I'm making wicked witch fingers
and I'm giving them an actual green colour
with the matcha.
[Sandi] She now juggles
jewellery making with being a new mum,
but Helena used to be
a professional poker player.
-Oh... [laughs]
-[Helena] Oh, yeah!
She's hoping to play a winning hand
with her severed shortbread digits,
covering them in green-coloured chocolate
for that authentic gangrenous touch.
I tried to turn down the gore
not to put you off too much.
I think you should turn it up a bit.
We asked for your personality
and we're getting it.
-[Helena] Yeah.
-Witches' fingers. I'm all over this.
-What's in there, dead bees?
-I wouldn't put it past myself. [chuckles]
[Noel] Michelle's planning
to enchant the judges
with something a little more traditional.
[Michelle] I am making Bakewell bars.
I love cherry Bakewell,
so it's my go-to all the time.
[Noel] A huge rugby fan...
[both] Go on, boys.
...Michelle's man of the match
is always son Alfie.
[both] Go on, Alf. Well done.
[Noel] Cherry Bakewell
may be her go-to,
but for this bake, Michelle's opted
for another fruity flavour.
[Michelle] I've gone with raspberry,
because I've got so much sweet stuff,
I thought that would balance
the flavours a little better.
[Sandi] Alice's inspiration comes from
further afield than Bakewell.
I used to live in New Zealand.
It's my favourite place in the world,
and they do amazing chocolate biscuits
and sweets and everything.
So, a combination of, like, peanut slab,
mallow puff, and hokey pokey,
which is what they call honeycomb.
[Sandi] Globe-trotter Alice
hits the high seas in her spare time
as an officer in
the Royal Navy Combined Cadet Force.
Her three-in-one tribute
to Kiwi confectionery
will feature marshmallow
and salted peanut caramel
on a honeycomb-flavoured base.
[Alice] I'm about to bake my biscuits.
Oh, it's off. Rookie error, isn't it?
You turn your oven on.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Hopefully it heats up quickly.
-It's so relaxing.
-Good? It's nice.
Is that Paul's rolling pin?
Yeah, wait till I've tried
the biscuit cutters on you.
[Noel] The high sugar content of biscuits
means not only are they quick to bake...
[Priya] They're in for 15 minutes.
[Amelia] 10 minutes, 160.
[Noel] ...but also to burn.
They're going in at 160 for 9 minutes.
Half an hour in...
see where we're at. [laughs]
[Helena] Difficult to know
when they're ready.
I'll keep an eye when they start
browning on the sides.
It's there now.
[exhales]
Right, make a marshmallow now.
-[Noel] Whatever their filling...
-[groans] Fudge.
...the judges will expect the flavour...
[Rosie] That's my jelly. I want them
to taste the lime and the mint.
I want them to get both.
-This is coffee and cardamom mousse.
-[Noel] ...and texture...
Biggest worry is that not setting in time.
...to perfectly complement their biscuit.
It's not puffed up a lot,
but it'll set like a marshmallow.
-[mixer whirring]
-Paul can't hear me saying that,
so it should be okay.
I'm making a nougat.
You have to toast the pistachios.
If you put cold nuts in, it'll seize up,
so the nuts have to be warm,
as warm as the nougat, really.
It's just nice to have toasted nuts.
[Sandi] International health advisor David
makes sure every workout
with boyfriend Nick
-ends in some carb-loading.
-[both laugh]
As well as pistachio, David's adding
another nutty flavour to his nougat.
Coconut drops.
When I practised this,
I've not put enough in,
so now I'm just putting way more
than I did last time.
[Amelia] This is my rosehip syrup.
[Noel] Amelia, too, is risking
a potentially pungent nougat.
I go to Turkey a lot for work,
and they have nougat
that's got pistachio and rose.
The rosehip was a good shout from my mum.
I was gonna use rosewater,
but she was like,
"Ooh, I've got this,"
and it works really well.
[Sandi] When she's not
jetting off for work,
fashion designer Amelia
enjoys a kick-about with friends.
[cheering and laughing]
[singsongy] We won, we won, we won.
[Sandi] Her Turkish-inspired nougat
will sit atop a pistachio biscuit.
[Amelia] It still looks a bit soft,
but it's golden round the edges
so I don't wanna do it for longer.
Hopefully once it cools, it'll firm up.
Praying.
[Noel] With just seconds separating
underdone and overbaked...
I don't know whether to take it out.
It's just really buttery.
[Noel] ...achieving a batch of
identical perfectly baked biscuits...
One minute longer.
[Noel] ...is a trial of
the baker's experience and intuition.
[Henry] It's looking all right.
I might have gone a bit over,
but I'd prefer that to a soggy biscuit.
I'm gonna leave it in a few more minutes.
-Hi, Phil.
-Hello, mate. You all right?
-Hello, Phil.
-[Phil] Hello.
[Prue] Tell us about your chocolate bars.
This is shortbread with a white chocolate
fudge covered in chocolate.
Quite sweet, then?
Like a bit of sweetness.
[engine rumbling]
[Noel] Lorry driver Phil
also takes to the roads on his day off
as a member of his local biking club.
-All right, chaps?
-All right?
Have a fairy cake. Mmm.
[Noel] He's confident
his bars' sweetness
will be balanced
by the tangy orange zest in his shortbread
and dried cranberries in his fudge.
Who don't like chocolate?
Who don't like biscuit?
And who don't like... fudge?
[Sandi] With most of
the bakers' biscuits cooling...
[Jamie] It's not done.
[Sandi] ...they can turn
their attention to chocolate.
I'm using 70% cocoa solid,
so really quite a bitter dark chocolate.
[Helena] I'm just mixing the white
chocolate with green candy melts.
Anything witchy, I love to make.
[Michelle] I am painting
the inside of my moulds.
I've tried pouring it in,
but it didn't seem to set very well.
There's a lot of chocolate in here.
More than I need.
Just wanna get a good thick layer.
[Sandi] Perfectionist Priya
enjoys pushing herself...
[Priya grunts]
...and not just in the Pilates studio.
Oh, I'm jelly now. [groans]
[Sandi] As well as making
cardamom shortbread
and barfi, an Indian milk sweet,
she's experimenting with
a brand-new kind of chocolate.
-[Priya] This is ruby chocolate.
-Ruby what, sorry?
Ruby chocolate.
It's derived from a specific type
of cocoa bean.
It's slightly tangy,
works nicely with the flavours
I was trying to achieve.
It'll be interesting to see
-how the cardamom works with that.
-[Priya] Yeah.
-But good luck.
-Thank you.
[Henry] So, I am now going to assemble.
Just getting everything in the moulds.
I just hope they all come together.
I'm not doing moulds. I've just made
a traybake and I'm gonna chop it up.
My nougat and my biscuits
are still a bit soft.
Need to get 'em in the freezer
ASAP Rocky.
[Noel] Every minute
the bakers spend assembling
means less time
for their biscuit bars to chill and set...
The marshmallow is a bit soft. Ooh.
...increasing the risk
they'll serve up a molten mess.
[Jamie] I'm gonna pour the caramel in.
I need to cool it down. If it goes into
the chocolate like that, it could melt it.
Bit worried about time,
but just gotta wait.
[Henry] This is the mousse.
Ah! Why is it that soft?
Oh, dear.
My nougat.
It's getting stickier and stickier.
I'm trying to smooth off the edges.
It's a desperate move.
Whew.
Bakers, you have half an hour,
just half an hour. Cracking on.
Half an hour? Fucking hell.
I am cutting up my barfi layer,
then I'll be able to assemble.
[Steph] Just chucking chocolate on.
[gasps, chuckles] God's sake.
That's as nicely as I can feather,
so... going with.
I've just got to let it set, pray that
they actually come out the mould.
[Henry] Right, freezer. Freezer, freezer.
Ugh.
How long do we have?
Bakers, only 15 minutes left.
Fifteen.
They're not very set
but they're set enough.
[Jamie] My shortbreads,
they're falling apart.
[Henry] Just praying it comes out.
I'm panicking already.
Just please come out.
[Michael] Oh!
They've at least got one biscuit bar.
Oh!
They've all come out.
I'm not sure how. I'm amazed.
[Phil] Up against it.
Pick up, pick up, pick up.
[Jamie] They could've done
with more in the freezer.
They're a little bit not solid.
[Michelle] I've put some food colouring
just to splash it a bit.
I like things to look pretty.
[Helena] Does that look like blood? Yeah.
[Alice] Try and be neat with these. Ahh!
Okay, I've got spares, it's fine.
I've got spares.
-[Priya] Oh, God.
-[Jamie] They're not frozen enough.
Oh, look at that.
-[Michelle] What can I do?
-How long have we got?
Bakers, you have one minute left.
-[laughs]
-Oh.
-Do you want me to help decorate?
-[Jamie] Yeah.
Mm. These are so not set.
[Priya] If anybody wants to help.
Oh... [gasps]
-[Priya] Oh, my God, you guys.
-You're fine, you're fine.
What do we need to do?
-This is so embarrassing.
-[Michelle] They okay like that?
Don't be embarrassed,
just get them out as quick as you can.
[Henry] Jelly, jelly, jelly.
[Jamie] Wait, is there...
How many are there?
One, two, three, four, five...
-Two more.
-Eleven, eleven.
[Michelle] You're missing one.
Quick. Just... Just put it.
Right, my lovelies. Time is up.
[laughs]
Oh, thank you so much.
Please place your Signature bakes
at the end of your benches.
[Henry groans, chuckles]
-Nobody's listening.
-No.
Oh, what a dog's dinner that is.
-Oh, Michelle, yours look fit.
-Yeah, Michelle!
Hey, you haven't tasted them yet.
You haven't tasted them yet.
[Amelia] Oh, God. I'm dreading judging.
[Sandi] The bakers' chocolate biscuit bars
will now be judged by Prue and Paul.
-Hi.
-Hi, Michelle.
-Well, I have to say, they look exquisite.
-Thank you.
-They really do.
-I love that splash of colour.
They're all identical as well,
which I like.
Definitely taste like Bakewell.
First thing you get is almond.
The biscuit texture's very, very good.
The temptation to eat
this second mouthful is impossible.
-[laughter]
-Oh, thank you.
-[Prue] Very good.
-[Paul] They are unique.
I've never had anything like it before.
-I think they're exceptional. Well done.
-Thank you.
-[whispers] Well done.
[whispers] "Unique".
[Paul] Rough and ready, aren't they?
[Prue] Rustic.
I don't think that's cooked properly.
-Oh.
-[Paul] Your biscuit
could've done with
a bit more baking.
Feels like a paste.
-Okay.
-It does, yeah.
But the nougat's delicious.
-Thank you.
[Paul] They look
really neat actually.
You've got a beautiful shine
on that chocolate.
The mousse is right round the--
[Henry] The mousse
is round the shortbread.
It needed a bit longer
to set, that mousse.
I think the flavours are beautiful.
-That cardamom really lifts it up.
-So ambitious to do six layers.
Really, you've pulled it off,
-it's just that that mousse hasn't set.
-Yeah.
They look a bit messy on the side.
The nougat kind of sloughed out of it.
It didn't work as well...
-Sorry, "sloughed"?
-"Sloughed"?
Like when you've got
a sloughy wound,
-all the pus coming out of it.
-Just like that.
-It was kind of doing that.
-David, thank you.
[all laughing]
[Paul] I like the blend
of the nougat with the bitter chocolate,
and you do get that coconut as well.
-It just looks a bit messy.
-Yeah.
-But well slacked and sloughed.
-[chuckles]
I mean, they look quite chunky,
don't they? But they look neat.
[Prue] Hmm.
[Paul] The textures are good
except for the marshmallow.
The marshmallow's not quite right.
-[Paul] Not quite set.
-Yeah.
[Prue] I love the lemony middle.
I think that's genius.
The lemon and the rosemary
come through beautifully.
Marshmallow adds
a little bit of sweetness,
and the dark chocolate
that little bit of bitterness.
So you have the perfect blend
of all the flavours.
[laughter]
You all right, darling?
Do you want a chair?
-Thanks, Michael.
-Thank you.
[whispers] Yay. Well done.
Ah. [chuckles]
[Paul] They look fairly neat.
Pretty uniform.
I like the idea of this coffee biscuit.
Oh, no.
It's very crumbly.
I've put semolina in there.
Ah, that's what it is.
I like the crumbliness.
I'm less keen on the coffee flavour,
I think it's a bit too strong.
Okay.
They do look a bit messy.
-Thank you.
-[laughter]
Perhaps they taste better than they look.
[Paul chuckles]
Watch your fingers, Prue.
-[Prue] Remind me what the top is?
-[Phil] It's a fudge.
It's certainly a sugar rush.
It's a pleasant flavour.
Right at the end, you get the cranberries,
so you get that little kick of bitterness.
-You need that because it is sweet.
-Mm-hmm.
I just don't think
it looks particularly good.
-Take what you can get, Phil.
-[chuckles] Yeah.
I'll take that.
[Prue] I don't actually want to bite
the end off this finger.
-Think she nailed it.
-[laughter]
I'm working here, people.
I'm fearing Paul's reaction here.
It's a bit boring.
The biscuit's got that feeling
of being slightly stale.
It's almost got that flavour, to me,
of being slightly stale too.
Maybe you don't like
the flavour of matcha?
I understand. It's like Marmite.
-But they're very original.
-Thank you.
[Prue] They look absolutely identical.
They're nicely made.
[Paul] Let's have a look inside,
shall we?
Hmm. Very nice hokey-cokey flavour.
It's delicious 'cause you've got
so many textures,
including the honeycomb.
-The peanut's fantastic.
-Mm.
You've done really well.
-[inhales] Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done, Alice.
-Sigh of relief.
-[Alice mimics sigh]
-Yeah, thank you very much.
-Excellent.
-Thank you.
-Thank you. [sighs]
[Paul] I wanted something more,
even if you'd spun white chocolate on it
or done some effect.
You struggled with the time,
didn't you?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
This is going to be the first time
I've eaten ruby chocolate.
The chocolate's got a nice kick to it,
but it's too thick.
The biscuit inside, I'm not getting
any flavours 'cause what's happening is,
the chocolate's overtaken everything.
-Thank you.
-[whispers] Okay?
-Could've been worse.
-[Paul] What happened?
-I put the caramel in too hot.
It's like biscuits after an earthquake.
[laughter]
Jamie, that's an awful lot of caramel.
It's pretty sickly.
I can't really identify more flavours.
I wish I could say that it looks dreadful
and tastes fantastic,
-but...
-It looks great as well? [laughs]
[all laugh]
Funnily not.
-Thank you.
[Prue] They look absolutely magnificent.
Beautifully feathered.
I love that.
It's not too sweet.
I think the balance between
the lime and the mint is perfect.
The biscuits are beautiful.
And this is a biscuit bar
and we're really focussing on the biscuit.
It's biscuit week
and your biscuits are beautiful.
I think it's delicious. Thank you.
-Very good.
-Thanks.
[whispers] Well done. That was good.
[whispers] They liked my flavours.
They liked my flavours.
Really happy. [laughs]
Really relieved.
How dare he? How dare he?
The thing is, matcha is
a difficult flavour to sell.
I was hoping the flavour'd be
better than the look.
Unfortunately, it was probably worse.
[laughs]
[Alice] Really happy.
They'd gone the best
they've ever gone,
so, yeah, it's just
the miracle of the tent.
[birds chirping]
[Noel] While the bakers could practise
their chocolate biscuit bars,
their next challenge
is a complete mystery.
Bakers, welcome to everybody's
favourite part of the day. [chuckles]
Yay, the Technical Challenge,
that shot in the gingham-cupboard
baking dark.
-[chuckles]
-Today's Technical Challenge
has been set for you
by the delightful Paul.
Paul, any words of wisdom?
These are a favourite of my dad's,
but remember to be accurate and neat.
There we go.
Don't know if anyone
knows Paul's dad at all?
[all laugh]
As ever, the Technical
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna ask these two pretties
to leave the tent. Off you pop.
-Bye.
-Okay.
[Noel] Where are they going?
Prue's crimping Paul's hair
for the judging.
[laughs] He likes to look nice.
[Sandi] Ah, it's worth the effort.
For your Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to make 12 fig rolls.
-"Controversial," I hear you thinking.
-[Sandi] Mm.
Are they biscuits or are they cakes?
-I can feel a court case coming on.
-[bakers laugh]
Your fig rolls must use
a soft biscuit dough
and be filled
-with a lightly spiced fig filling.
-Mm-hmm.
-There's something else.
-Identical in shape and size.
-They need to be identical in shape and...
-[all laugh]
-It's a given at this point.
-Who knew? Who knew?
You have just 90 minutes.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Phew.
[Sandi] The bakers have
only an hour and a half
and Paul's pared-down recipe.
Oh, my God.
[Sandi] ...to create 12 perfect fig rolls.
I've never even eaten a fig roll.
[Alice] It's about getting it
the right texture, the right taste.
So, obviously,
if it's Paul's dad's favourite,
then they've gotta taste amazing.
[Jamie] I got the worst comments
this morning.
I wanna try and redeem myself a bit.
What could go wrong?
So, Mr Hollywood, fig rolls,
that's a bit of
a simple challenge, isn't it?
It's not as easy as they probably think.
There's several areas
where they could fall down.
One is the biscuit dough
on the outside.
Which is quite cakey, isn't it?
[Paul] It is. Very soft, very crumbly.
If it's too crumbly,
the whole thing will fall to pieces.
Two, it's about the accuracy
of how you cut it,
so they all look exactly the same.
And then three,
the temptation is to overbake these
and try and put a strong colour on.
[Prue] Nice pale biscuit colour,
-isn't it?
-It is.
The figs are beautifully balanced
with the cinnamon.
Hint of ginger, that stem ginger
right at the back. They're delicious.
I remember growing up with my dad
eating these,
watching the wrestling
on a Saturday afternoon.
How many could he eat?
He'd probably go through a packet.
Well, roll on fig rolls.
[laughs]
[Phil] Here we go.
It just says, "Using the creaming method,
make the biscuit dough."
[Michael] Very simple instructions.
"Make the biscuit dough."
This guy sells recipe books, mate.
[Steph] We've got unsalted butter,
muscovado sugar,
and some icing sugar for dusting.
I'm a bit confused.
I did the dough with the icing sugar.
The muscovado might be
for the figs, but I'm not sure.
In the fridge now for 30 minutes.
-[Noel] What's this?
-[Helena] Figs.
[Noel] They're figs.
They look delicious.
Have one.
They don't look like monkey testicles
in any way. [laughs]
"Cook the figs in sugar and water
until thick.
Blitz into a paste with the spices."
How much? It doesn't say that.
Paul said "lightly spiced",
so I'm not gonna put loads in.
[Michael] I think
a tiny bit of spices at a time,
'cause like Paul said last week,
"You can always add,
but you can't take away."
-I'm putting in a healthy amount, I think.
-Ooh.
I'm going minimal.
He said, "lightly." Light, light.
What I don't want them to say is that
they can't taste any of the spices.
I can't taste anything but sweetness.
[coughs]
[Amelia] My dough's had its 30 minutes.
Just rolling it out
to the rectangle that I've drawn.
Quite hard to roll it out.
[Helena] It's just so soft, this dough.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You've got 45 minutes left.
Just looking for one of Prue's earrings.
So, "Divide the fig filling
down the middle of each strip."
Just going to pipe the filling in
just to make it neater.
Doesn't look very appealing, does it?
And then roll. How do I roll it?
I'm rolling it like a Swiss roll,
'cause I make Swiss rolls all the time.
[Michael] It says "roll and seal".
I've kind of rolled.
I'm not that confident in my technique.
There's something not quite right.
Man, they are sticky.
I hope I can pull it back.
[Michael] "Cut each roll
into six equal pieces
and transfer onto a lined baking sheet."
Might be a bit small, but, oh, well.
[Phil] Six and six. Twelve fig rolls.
[Rosie] Michael, no.
-What have I done?
-[Rosie] How many?
Six. Twelve.
Cut them in half. Quick. Go.
Cut them in half. Oh! That was close.
Half an hour of fig roll fun left, people.
[David] "Run a fork
along the top of the fig rolls
to decorate with visible lines
and to slightly flatten them."
I'm just gonna do a light imprint there.
Hm. They're not, like, 100% identical,
but they're not bad.
[Helena] Oh, my God.
Looks perfect. You should see mine.
You've got biscuit in your hair.
-I like it like that. That's...
-Oh.
Want me to put it back?
It makes it look like I've tried.
[Phil] Just gotta bake 'em now.
The question is
how long do you bake 'em for?
I'll just give Paul's dad a ring.
Do you know his number?
I don't think
they're gonna take very long.
[Amelia] I might give 'em 20 minutes.
I'm going for golden brown.
[Alice] I reckon 15 minutes.
[Jamie] I'm egg-washing 'em.
It doesn't say to, but you've gotta
give 'em an extra edge.
And it always makes things look nice.
[Rosie] Be good. Be good.
I don't feel like they're a car crash,
so that's good.
I looked at them,
but I don't know what I was looking for.
Do you wanna play a game?
-Everyone always starts with scissors.
-Is that a thing?
-Yeah, should've gone with...
-Okay, ready? Okay.
-Still went with scissors.
-Yeah. [laughs]
They're beginning to go brown
around the edges.
Speak to the people, Noel.
You have five minutes remaining.
I'm gonna take 'em out.
Only one person's got theirs out yet,
so I'm okay.
I think I'm gonna take mine out.
-[David] Yes, I'm happy.
-[Michael] No, I'm not.
Oh, no, I am. No, I'm not.
-[timer beeping]
-They look fig roll-ish to me.
-One, two, three, four, five, six...
Oh. I thought I didn't have
the right number then.
[Helena] ...eight, nine, ten, eleven.
[gasps] No.
How did I do that?
I'm in trouble.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Priya] Dust with icing sugar.
I've never dusted things with such care.
I'm trying to put similar ones together.
[David] And they are done.
Bakers, that is the end
of your Technical Challenge.
David's look actually identical.
How do yours look so good?
No, I definitely did 11. I'm a moron.
Please bring your fig rolls and place them
behind the photograph of your choice.
[laughter]
[Michelle] I'll swap.
Yours are cute.
[Noel] Paul and Prue
are looking for 12 identical fig rolls
with a smooth soft biscuit and a filling
which perfectly balances
cinnamon, ginger and fig.
Right, shall we start over here, Prue?
-They're a bit...
-[Prue] Flat.
[Paul] And I think slightly overbaked.
[Prue] Yeah.
They actually taste rather good.
Pastry's nice.
[Paul] Now these, not a bad colour.
[Prue] Yeah, they look
absolutely identical, don't they?
[Paul] They do.
The pastry's slightly cakey,
-but still crisp.
-[Paul] The flavour's good.
Now, this one looks a nice colour.
Bit small.
-Getting the ginger.
-[Prue] Yeah.
[laughing] It's strong in ginger. Wow.
Now, this mixture's gone quite flat,
but they are all the same.
-The balance is there with the flavours.
-Very nice.
[Paul] This one's not been mixed properly.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] It's broken up. It's overbaked.
Yeah. Pastry's quite tough, too.
That's because it's been overworked.
This is more like the right shape.
-[Paul] It is a nice shape.
-[Prue] And they're quite nice and full.
Nice pastry.
-It's got... [clears throat]
-Some ginger?
-Yeah, and cinnamon.
-[Prue laughs] Just a bit.
[Paul] Now, this one,
some are flat and some are thin.
It's how they've rolled it up.
Hm. And they're not
absolutely the same shape
Yeah. It's the flavours.
-I'm not getting any cinnamon or ginger.
-Feels dry.
Well, these aren't flattened at all.
-[Paul] No, they're not flattened.
-[Prue] But they are very beautiful.
[Paul] Plenty of filling in it,
and they are neat.
[Prue] I think that is very delicious.
It's got just a hint of cinnamon
and ginger.
[Paul] Now, there's an issue here
with the dough itself.
The pastry's very soft
and it's flattened out.
-This one, actually, has only got 11.
-[Prue] You're absolutely right.
The least of the problems.
[Prue laughs] That is not a fig roll.
I can't believe they've egg-washed it.
It's like a sausage roll.
It is like a sausage roll.
But they're very neat.
-It's quite tough, that pastry, isn't it?
-It is a bit.
-These are a little bit flat and uneven.
-[Paul] See how rough it is?
It needed a little bit longer,
just folding together.
And a lot of ginger.
[Paul] Last but not least.
Again, this has a problem with the dough.
It's very mottled. It's not smooth.
That's got a punch with the spice as well.
-[Prue] Yes, slightly over-flavoured.
-[Paul] Mm, it is.
[Sandi] Prue and Paul will now
rank the fig rolls from worst to best.
Twelfth place is this one.
Helena, you were one short
and they were a fair old disaster.
The person in eleventh spot is this one.
You egg-washed them.
It's not a sausage roll.
[Sandi] Steph came tenth,
ninth was Amelia,
eighth Michelle,
Priya came seventh.
Henry was sixth,
Rosie fifth
and Michael fourth.
In third spot, we have this one.
These were pretty good.
Do you like fig rolls, Phil?
-No.
-[laughter]
It's a shame.
You just overbaked them slightly,
-but they're nice.
-Thank you.
And in second place is this one.
David, they were absolutely perfect,
except they were, funnily enough
for a roll, too round.
[Paul] And in first spot...
Alice, well done.
Pastry's nice and smooth,
your filling was good,
and it was baked almost perfectly.
-Aww.
-[Alice chuckles] Oh.
What? [laughs]
Yeah, I won a Technical. It's amazing.
I can't believe that.
Never made a fig roll before.
Probably won't make them again.
Third? Yes, I am... I'll take that.
Paul looked like he wanted to kill
whoever put that egg glaze on. [laughs]
It's not looking good for me.
[Amelia] Today was a bit disappointing,
a bit down-heartening,
but start fresh tomorrow.
Just throw everything at it.
[Helena] I know
I have to nail the Showstopper.
If I don't, then I go home.
[Noel] Just the Showstopper
Challenge remains.
The bakers' last chance
to prove themselves
before one is crowned Star Baker
and another leaves the tent.
Hello, bakers.
Today, Paul and Prue
would like you to make
an edible masterpiece
in the form of a 3D biscuit sculpture.
[Sandi] You are gonna have
to treat your biscuit dough
like a sculptor would treat their clay.
You've basically gotta be
the Michelangelo of dough.
-Wow, really?
-I'm rapping information now.
[Sandi] Okay. Loving it. The judges are
looking for different shapes, textures
and thicknesses of biscuit
all combined together
to make a stunning 3D biscuit sculpture.
I never tire of saying those words.
[Noel] You have four hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
[Sandi] Bake.
[Michelle] "Melt butter, sugar and syrup."
[sighs]
[Michael] I'm feeling quite nervous
because I'm worrying I've bitten off
more than I can chew.
[Jamie] With what's happened
so far this weekend,
it's gonna have to be good,
so it's a little bit more pressure.
I wanna be able
to get to the Showstopper
without having to panic
that if anything goes wrong, I'm out.
Just not making things easy for myself.
This is a really jolly challenge.
It's technically difficult
and it's very creative.
You could pretty much
make anything in biscuit,
but they've gotta think of something
that's gonna impart flavour
but also be structurally sound.
Would you use a shortbread?
Possibly, if it's strong enough.
I reckon a lot of people
will go for gingerbread
because it's stable and it actually
tastes good baked properly.
This is a sculpture, so, of course
we want it to look absolutely amazing.
But this is a baking competition.
Frankly, if it doesn't taste good,
I don't care how beautiful it is.
-[Paul] Helena, hello.
-[Helena] Hi.
Tell us all about your sculpture.
I'm making a spider
coming out of an egg.
-Course you are. Brilliant.
-Of course you are.
So delicious,
they make your mouth water.
[Sandi] Helena's chocolate
orange tarantula
will scuttle out of a shortbread egg
flavoured with lemon zest
and Earl Grey tea leaves.
I tried Earl Grey shortbread years ago
and I couldn't find a recipe for it,
so I tried adding tea
just out of a teabag.
[Prue] That sounds a good idea.
It's very original.
[Noel] Steph's animal inspiration
is a little more cuddly.
So, my bis-cat is called Ginge.
I've got cats. I haven't got a ginger cat,
but I would love a ginger cat.
[Noel] Her bis-cat will have a brandy
snap tail and a spiced shortbread fur.
She'll mould the rest of its anatomy
from her punchy gingerbread.
I love a bit of ginger,
so it's all going in.
And if they don't like it, I do.
[Sandi] Whatever biscuit they've chosen...
Quite a lot of my sculpture
is lemon shortbread.
[Sandi] ...it not only
needs to be delicious...
This is cardamom, pistachio, coconut.
I just like the flavours.
...but also able to support the impressive
structures the judges are expecting.
-[Steph] Lot of biscuit dough.
-[Alice] It needs to be strong.
It's not gonna be crumbly at all.
[laughs] I think my mixer's having
a bit of a hard time at the moment.
[Noel] And the larger they go,
the sturdier
their biscuit will have to be.
I am making a really big chicken.
She's made of a spicy gingerbread
to reflect her spicy character.
She's the chicken
that survived our fox attack,
so she's a really tough
independent woman.
[Noel] Rosie's replica
of her favourite chicken, Legs,
will be made from 212 individual biscuits.
[Rosie] I think I've been
really ambitious, probably over-ambitious.
I'm doing the most biscuits
and the biggest thing,
so that's obviously making me feel
super-relaxed and super-confident.
[Sandi] Phil is also creating a tribute
to a cherished pet.
[Phil] Me and my sister
had a little tortoise called Tina.
But she's no longer with us.
The tortoise. My sister is,
but my tortoise is not.
[Sandi] He'll fashion
the dear-departed Tina's shell
from a sugar biscuit
covered in Florentines,
and her head and legs from brandy snap.
You used to take it for a walk
down the park?
Yeah, I used to take it for a drag.
On a string? On a skateboard? [laughs]
-Yeah.
-[both laugh]
-How'd he die?
-[Phil] I don't know.
Must have been of old age.
What did your tortoise die of, Phil?
-Don't know, didn't look into it.
-[Phil] I don't know. No.
Didn't even bury it,
just threw it in a skip.
[both laugh]
[Sandi] Michael is adding
to the growing menagerie.
I'm making a Highland cow.
He's called Hamish.
When I was a kid,
we used to explore the Highlands a lot
'cause that's where we lived.
So it's based on my memories of those
when I was wee.
[Sandi] His bovine biscuit sculpture
will feature two types of gingerbread.
Its fur will be chocolate and orange
while the head itself
will be more picante.
The judges might think
it's got a bit too much chilli in it.
I'm adding five teaspoons.
I like there to be a real kick.
I like it to be fiery.
[Sandi] And his is not
the only sculpture packing heat.
I'm making a dragon.
I wanted to make something
my little boys will find impressive.
[Sandi] The wings of Priya's dragon
will be covered
in delicate langues de chat biscuits,
while its brandy snap flames stand ready
to ward off any rivals.
Michelle is doing a dragon too.
Star Baker Michelle.
No pressure. No pressure at all.
[Michelle] Priya's is probably
gonna be way better than mine.
That's if I manage
to finish it on time. [chuckles]
[Noel] For her dragon,
Michelle's going all out
with four types of biscuit,
including a cardamom and pistachio neck
and gingerbread wings.
[Michelle] Well, obviously I am Welsh,
so I had to go
with the Dewi y Ddraig Cymraeg,
which is the Welsh dragon.
But it's also the emblem of the rugby team
that I support, the Scarlets.
So I'm doing it for Wales today.
I'm lining my tin with the gingerbread.
This is the body of the chicken.
This is either top half or bottom half.
They're interchangeable.
[Priya] These are my wings.
[Sandi] Getting their larger
building blocks in the oven
as quickly as possible is vital.
This is gonna be the head of Ginger.
Might have gone a bit thin on this.
[Michael] I am cutting out hair-shaped
bits of chocolate orange dough,
so it bakes on to the gingerbread.
It's sort of a cubist cow.
[Phil] In. Be kind.
[Sandi] The longer they take,
the less time the bakers will have
for their equally essential
smaller biscuits.
I'm moulding the spider by hand.
They're beautiful creatures.
[Rosie] I've piped my cones,
wattles, feet and beak.
All the essentials for a chicken,
and then I'll get going
on all the feather ones.
Time pressure is really on.
-Good morning, Henry.
-Hello.
[Prue] Hello, Henry.
-[Sandi] Hi, darling.
-[Paul] This looks interesting.
Biscuit sculpture.
What are you doing?
Yes, I'm making an organ.
-Kidney? Heart? Lung?
-A musical...
-A church one.
-Oh, right.
-[Paul] Ah. Right, okay.
-Chapel one. That wasn't specific enough.
[Noel] Henry's pulling out all the stops
with his organ,
adorning its gingerbread body
with edible stained glass windows
and towering brandy snap pipes.
How big's your organ gonna be?
-Well...
-[laughter]
About the size of this baking sheet
and about that tall. That's the plan.
[Sandi] I'm gonna
have to take Paul away now.
Please take him away.
-[Sandi] If that's okay.
-Thanks, Henry.
[chuckles]
[Sandi] Jamie's also looking
to strike a chord with his sculpture.
I'm making a guitar
'cause I play the guitar. [chuckles]
This is just, like, the various parts.
I don't even know what it's called,
but it's the bit that the strings go into.
[Sandi] The bridge, neck,
back and sides of his guitar
will be made from chocolate gingerbread.
While for the top,
he's revisiting a biscuit
from yesterday's Signature Challenge.
[Jamie] This is a lemon shortbread.
[laughs] It's actually
a different shortbread recipe,
so hopefully it'll go a bit better.
[David] Everyone else
seems to be very sophisticated
and has all these fancy stencil things.
I've got some recycled paper from work.
So I'm making flowers.
They're gonna look like flowers
from, like, another planet.
[Noel] David not only wants his
extraterrestrial blooms to look stellar,
but the taste to be out of this world.
Flavours are the things
I care about the most.
So this one is fennel and lime.
And then a grapefruit and caraway.
And another one cardamom and lemon.
-Quite citrusy.
-Yeah.
Yeah, and the idea
is hopefully to get the citrus first
and then the spice comes through
fragrantly afterwards.
I think if you can pull it off,
it'll be brilliant.
This is the sea.
I'm sort of piping waves and stuff.
Trying to recreate when I went swimming
with dolphins as a kid.
[Noel] As well as a Viennese whirl ocean,
Amelia's seascape
will feature three large waves
made from stacked lemon shortbreads.
[Amelia] Main worry
is running out of time,
so I'm pressing, like,
1A, 2A, etc. into the biscuit
so I know which one's which.
If I take time
making sure the biscuits are right,
once I come to put it together,
it'll all pay off and be a bit easier.
[Noel] Bakers, you are halfway through.
You have two hours left.
-Sorry I'm late.
-No, no, you were great.
Was I? I did it.
-Best I've ever seen you.
-Okay.
[Amelia] We're going in.
I'm just waiting
for my gingerbread wings to come out.
[Henry] Happy, I think.
I still need to make
the brandy snap organ pipes.
[Sandi] With only one oven...
[Michael] Ooh, non-stop.
...it will be a monumental test
of the bakers' skill
to achieve a perfectly uniform bake...
Yeah, happy with that.
Gonna get the next ones in.
[Sandi] ...across multiple batches
of different biscuits.
Are all the limbs out?
[Amelia] The small ones
are a little bit overdone.
The big ones look all right.
What, are these ears?
Ears? They're feathers.
They look like ears. [laughs]
These are my cardamom biscuits.
I'm gonna put them in
for ten minutes and check.
[Phil] This is the Florentines.
I've just gotta
let 'em cool a little bit so I can
cut 'em out to the shape that I need.
[Alice] I've absolutely no idea
how many macarons I'm doing.
I just need to make sure
I've got enough for all the wool.
I'm continuing with my New Zealand theme,
so this is gonna be a New Zealand lamb.
[Noel] Alice's lamb will sit
in a shortbread pen
and sport a luxuriant
coconut macaron fleece.
-Is that more wool over there?
-Yeah, I've got loads of--
-Smaller wool?
-Smaller wool.
So that's wool,
and that's wool in the distance.
-Yeah.
-Is it just in the distance?
-No, it's...
-It's actually smaller.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-There's gonna be variations in size.
-I've never understood perspective.
-Everyth--
-Aren't you an artist?
I'm like a bumblebee. I can't see depth.
Okay.
-Okay, I'm gonna leave it there.
-Well, hopefully...
-Good luck, yeah?
-Hopefully, this makes sense.
[Noel] Just one hour remains.
[Alice] Some last-minute fence building.
This is my coconut-and-lime shortbread.
[Amelia] This is the start
of construction.
[Phil] The risky bit. That collapses,
I might as well walk home.
And breathe.
So I'm gonna make caramel
to stick it together.
The assembly's the worst bit.
[Rosie] I'm terrified about assembling it.
If the glue doesn't work,
this is what I've got.
[exhales]
[Amelia] I'm just going as fast as I can.
And my numbers are helping.
Best thing I've ever done.
Six.
[Alice] Just gonna construct
my little sheep now.
I actually went to art school
in New Zealand,
and I did sculpture at art school,
so hopefully, I can kind of recreate
the skill that I had there.
[Rosie] This is really, really soft,
this gingerbread,
which is not good.
[Jamie] This is the bit
that wraps around the side.
Oh, look at that.
I knew that would happen.
I thought I'd be more ahead of this
than I am.
If things go wrong again,
then I might be stuffed.
[Helena] I'm gonna have to hold the legs
just until they're stabilised.
This is staying put. Good girl.
[Sandi] Oh, the organ arises.
-Okay, bit too much? I'll start again.
-[chuckles]
I'm putting in the second one now.
Nobody move. [laughs]
Well, I've never said it before,
but I'm loving your organ.
[Sandi and Henry laugh]
[Priya] They're the feathers
for the dragon.
[Noel chuckles] Hello, Michelle.
-[Michelle] Hello.
-[Noel] What are you doing?
[Michelle] This is fire
for my dragon's mouth.
[Noel] I think there's another dragon
in here.
[Michelle whispers]
Yes, there is another dragon.
-Are you annoyed about that?
-No, I'm not.
I just haven't got the time to speak.
[Noel] You know what?
Yours looks good though.
I've only done wings.
That's all I've managed
to get out at the minute.
Oh, is that what they are?
[Michael] Stuck them on the wrong sides.
Damn.
[sighing]
It looks really messy.
I just don't feel confident
that I can do it now. [sighs]
[Priya] Don't. If you get upset,
I'll cry, honestly.
I can't bear it. I can't.
-Don't, please don't.
-Thank you.
[Priya] Okay, 'cause I'll start crying
if you start crying. I mean it.
[Michael] Come on. Come on.
Come on, Michael.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have just half an hour.
You can do this.
[Michael] I can't.
I didn't hear you say "I can't".
I said you can. You can.
Right, what's next?
[Phil] Just about to make the legs,
head and tail from brandy snap.
[Steph] This is for the tail of my cat.
It's quite dark, that.
[exhales deeply]
Gonna start the decoration.
[Alice] This is coconut
and white chocolate buttercream.
[Helena] I'm painting dark chocolate
with a little bit of orange zest,
so then I can sprinkle toasted coconut
and make it look like hairs.
[Michelle] This is really important.
This is what makes it look scaly,
my dragon.
[Phil] Make it stand out in the dark.
You don't want to tread on it,
do you?
I don't think
things need to be bright-coloured.
Classy is sometimes nicer.
Gold star for me.
[Amelia] What are you doing with them?
[Henry] Stained glass windows.
[Amelia] Oh, beautiful.
Everyone's is looking really good.
I'm making a spider web with spun sugar.
Ooh, God.
[chuckles] I'm just trying
to make some black icing
so I can pipe some hair.
[sighs] I'm going cross-eyed.
-Bakers, you have one minute left.
-One minute.
[Henry] I'm gonna pipe some music notes.
[Amelia] I look like an old lady.
This is hilarious.
[sighs] How long? How long?
[Phil] Running out of time rather quickly.
[Jamie] That's never gonna
stay on in a million years,
unless I propped it up with that.
Just the eggs.
[sighs]
[Sandi] That is the end of your time.
Please step away from your Showstoppers.
-[Jamie] Oh, my days.
-[Rosie sighs] Done.
[sighs]
[Alice] He looks like a sheep.
[Jamie] I'm glad I finished.
[sighs]
[Helena] Done.
[Sandi] Prue and Paul will now judge
the bakers' biscuit sculptures.
[Noel] David, would you like
to bring up your Showstopper?
-[Sandi] Want a hand?
-No, I'm okay.
-[Noel] Not with those guns.
-[all laugh]
[Paul] It looks beautiful, the work
you've done with the shortbread,
you've done an amazing job.
And the decoration is so skilful.
It's beautifully done.
[Paul] Very delicate.
[crunching]
Delicious.
The fennel really works
with the citrus together.
The tuiles are delicious.
They snap.
You've thought that through.
I think that's excellent, David.
-[Noel] Well done.
-[Sandi] Well done, darling. Excellent.
I think it looks great. It is ingenious.
Oof. There's some chilli in there,
isn't there?
In fact, there's a lot of chilli in there.
[inhales sharply]
I quite like it. It's underbaked,
it's gone really soft.
But the heat coming through is great.
[Prue] I'm a little disappointed, Henry.
I had this vision of being able to see
all the pipes soaring up to the heavens.
-Yeah.
-Where's the keyboard?
Er, the... It... The lid's closed.
-That's handy.
-[laughter]
[crunching]
They're certainly crisp,
but they're a bit too thick.
Pull my teeth out. [chuckles]
[Paul] I think your flavours
are delicious,
but they're a bit too thick,
them, for sure.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-You could've done better.
[Paul] It's a cat version of
a gingerbread house. It's very clever.
-Oh, dear.
-[Sandi] Ah.
It's nice and thin.
Snaps beautifully.
Good kick of ginger at the end,
-but I think it's slightly overbaked.
-Okay.
[Prue] I think it's so clever
the way you've curved the legs slightly
in the way that tortoises
get along. [laughs]
[Sandi] I love you doing
a tortoise impersonation.
That's, er... That's made my day,
that has.
[Paul] I'd have liked to have seen
more colour on those Florentines.
They need to be in the oven much longer.
It's way underdone.
-[Prue] Mm, yeah.
-[Paul] It's a shame.
I was expecting a bit more
definition on the dolphin.
I can't really make it out. [laughs]
Amelia, I'm a little disappointed
that you used stacking.
We did say we wanted you
to use dough as if it was clay.
It's got a nice snap to it.
I think they're baked well,
although it could carry more flavour.
I think it's okay.
It doesn't blow my mind.
Thank you.
[whispers] Never mind.
[Paul] That's highly impressive, Rosie.
It looks incredible.
[Prue] It's just stunning.
With little tuile-style biscuits,
which taste great.
[Prue] That's such a delicate biscuit.
It's really good.
The gingerbread is very, very soft,
-which is a shame.
-Okay.
[Paul] It needed a little bit longer
in the oven.
It's fascinating what you've done.
-I think artistically it is fantastic.
-Superb.
The whole composition is a triumph.
Thank you.
-You're a very, very clever vet.
-[chuckles]
[Prue] I think it's astonishing.
It's really elegantly done,
and the piping is exquisite.
[Paul] It's a work of art.
I think it's beautiful.
The colours look lovely.
The langues de chat,
they're disappointing.
They are really tough,
whereas langues de chat
should be very delicate.
The look of it is good,
but how many times have we said
style and substance?
You've got to have both.
I must say the dragon looks
a little clumsy.
-I ran out of time.
-[Prue] Yeah.
Remind me of the ingredients.
Pistachio, cardamom,
lemon zest and coconut.
I think that's one of the most
interesting biscuits I've ever tasted.
-[Sandi] Oh, wow.
-[Prue] It really is delicious.
It is packed with flavour,
and the texture's beautiful inside.
I think you've done Wales proud.
Oh, thank you. Mmm. [laughs]
-[Paul] Looks great.
-Thank you. [chuckles]
It's a very big sheep
in a very small field.
[laughing] It's very sweet.
[Paul] I think the macarons
have done a fantastic job.
-[Prue] Lovely.
-They do taste great.
The white chocolate and the coconut
really come through.
That shortbread is really citrusy
and sharp and lovely.
And it does break down beautifully
in the mouth, and it's well baked.
And I love the whole sculpture,
because it's funny.
I think that's a fine piece of work.
-Thank you so much.
-[Prue] Really good.
[Prue] Well, it's unmistakably a guitar.
It's quite simple.
It's all a little thick and clumsy.
And there's too much icing on there.
Your piping is, erm, not the best.
-Beautiful biscuit.
-Oh, thank you.
Delicate, light, lovely lemon flavour
coming through.
That biscuit is so delicious.
Decoration's not bad.
I quite like the colour.
-It's just a little bit clumsy.
-[Jamie] Yeah.
-[Paul] I think you could've done better.
-Yeah.
I think that is the most sculptural piece.
Artistically it's superb.
The spider looks very impressive.
[Prue] The Earl Grey is interesting,
the leaves in the shortbread.
I'd never have thought of that,
but it actually works.
I think I have to eat
a bit of the spider too now.
That works beautifully as well.
It's nice and bitter.
[Prue] Very interesting.
-[Helena] You can have it, Noel.
-[laughter]
Your friend. Are you happy now?
[Sandi] It was crawling
towards you anyway.
[Paul] Overall, I think you've done
an amazing job.
You've obviously got
a massive artistic flair. It's magical.
Oh, thank you, Paul.
-[David] That's really cool.
-Absolutely amazing.
I should be euphoric, I'm still worried.
Getting sweaty palms again.
[Jamie] I was really happy
with the comments on the shortbread.
I could've probably done better,
but it's just the pressure of the tent.
I don't think they've seen me at my best,
but it's out of my hands now.
[Amelia] The comments from the judges
were disappointing. I could be in danger.
There's always a chance
that two of us can go,
but I hope it's not today,
'cause then there's more of
a chance that it'll be me. [laughs]
[Noel] It's decision time
for Paul and Prue.
Who will be the Star Baker,
and who will leave the tent?
Here's something I never thought I'd say.
What about that chicken?
-[Prue] Wasn't it amazing?
-[Sandi] It was fantastic.
[Noel] Powerful.
[Paul] Rosie's doing well, actually.
I think, overall,
there's some people that really excelled.
David did well.
-I thought his Showstopper was amazing.
-It was amazing.
-[Paul] Those flowers.
-[Prue] It was exquisite.
-[Paul] And Alice.
-[Prue] Alice's sheep
made me laugh so much. It was such
a sweet sheep, but really well baked.
So they're in line for Star Baker.
I thought Helena
coming into this challenge
was in a little bit of trouble,
but that spider, unbelievable.
But that is what can happen
in the Showstopper, isn't it?
-It just bumps them straight up.
-[Paul] Yeah.
[Sandi] It feels as though
Amelia's in some trouble.
[Paul] I think Amelia struggled.
Biscuits are not her thing.
And Jamie. He was eleventh in Technical
and bad in the Signature.
[Prue] His Showstopper tasted delicious
but quite clumsy-looking.
I think either one of those could go.
Or two.
-Or two.
Could we go?
-Absolutely.
-Okay.
[Sandi] Well done, bakers.
That is week two in the bag.
Many congratulations. Now, I do not think
it is going to be a surprise to anybody
when I announce who is the Star Baker.
It is somebody who pretty much nailed
in first place every single one
of the three challenges.
This week's Star Baker is Alice.
[cheering and applause]
That leaves me with the horrible job
of announcing who's leaving us.
And the person who's leaving us
this week is...
Jamie. [tsks] Sorry, mate.
It's all right.
-[chuckles]
-[Michelle] Aw.
I think it's sort of mixed emotions.
Obviously, I'm a bit gutted,
but I'm also, like, proud of myself
for what I've done.
You don't get in the tent
unless you're a good baker. Don't stop.
It's just a great experience,
that's why I just don't want it to end.
I'm just mainly gonna miss everyone, so...
What a bittersweet moment.
I'm absolutely devastated for Jamie.
Obviously, I'm relieved that it's not me.
Through to next week.
That's a relief, definitely.
I'm just really determined
to prove it to myself
that I'm good enough to be here.
[Amelia] Alice. Well done, mate.
You deserved it.
You did really, really well.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I'm Star Baker.
-Thank you so much.
-[Prue] You deserved it.
[laughs] Thank you.
I'm so happy. Just over the moon.
Hi, Ede, it's me.
-[woman on phone] Hello, darling.
-[man on phone] How'd you do? How'd it go?
I got Star Baker.
-[man on phone] Well done.
-[woman on phone] Oh, wow! Wow! Wow!
[Alice laughs] You're on speakerphone,
by the way.
-[woman on phone] I'm on camera?
-[Alice] Yeah.
[woman on phone] Oh, my God.
I'm eating my salad here,
and I've got bits of cress in my teeth.
-[laughing]
-Oh, darling...